and joining us now the governor of
nebraska pete ricketts governor welcome
to fox news sunday
good morning thanks for having me on i
want to start with something that you
said this week about president biden's
new vaccine mandates here you are sir
the president's forgotten we live in
america he thinks we live in the soviet
union and the hypocrisy of this is just
unbelievable
governor what's so objectionable about
biden's vaccine mandates and what are
you going to do about it
well first of all we have been
encouraging people to get vaccinated
we've been providing information and
encouraging people to reach out to their
neighbors because vaccines work and they
will help people
but it should be a personal healthcare
choice this is not something that the
government should mandate and somebody
shouldn't have to make the choice
between keeping their job and getting a
jab in the arm i mean it's just wrong
i've talked to people number a number of
people who have told me if they made me
take the vaccine i'm just going to be
fired i'm not going to i'm not going to
do it
but you say it's a personal choice in
fact
to attend school in your state of
nebraska children must be vaccinated
against a number of diseases let me put
them up on the screen they must be
vaccinated against diphtheria
tetanus and pertussis
polio measles mumps and rubella
hepatitis b and chickenpox
why
are those mandates that parents in your
state must comply with
and do comply with routinely
why is it that they're not
so objectionable and such a violation of
personal freedom but biden's vaccine
mandates are
well for all those that you just listed
there's a long history that parents have
had the opportunity to see how those
things have been implemented
and there's still a lot of people out
there who don't know what to trust and
in fact this is really an outcome of
what the cdc has done because they've
flip-flopped on so many issues whether
it's mass or whether you have to mask
after you've been vaccinating and so
forth there's just a lot of people out
there who don't know who to trust right
now and so by having the government
force it on you're not building the
trust where we have the trust with those
other vaccines
this is a process going to take time to
bring people along and that's why it
should be a personal choice and not
something mandated by the government but
but forgive me sir i'm old enough that i
remember when the polio vaccine first
came out uh a lot of us and certainly
our parents viewed it as a blessing and
immediately i lived in new york state at
that time the state mandated that we all
get the polio vaccine so you know we're
in the middle of a pandemic there is a
new vaccine that donald trump was
largely responsible for it's been
approved full approval by the fda
again if if
polio vaccine is okay for for parents
and they have to comply with it to send
their kid to school why not for
a lot of people not just kids
the vaccine
for uh for this disease
yeah and i think this is very different
from polio that has very devastating
effects and certainly we know if you're
older you know 65 years and older that's
where 83 of our deaths in nebraska came
from we know this is really devastating
but we also know that nearly 87 percent
of our 65 years and older population
has been vaccinated and if you're
looking at young children for example
here in nebraska we can look at the data
and see that really children are no more
at risk for the coronavirus than they
are for the ordinary flu and so it's all
about balancing off these risks and the
risk for this is just such where this is
something that we shouldn't be mandating
it
again the whole goal for all we're doing
at least in nebraska how we're doing it
is around making sure we're preserving
hospital capacity and we've successfully
done that here even without max man
doing statewide mass mandates and
without doing vaccine passports so let's
let's keep the objective in mind which
is to be able to provide health care and
which we've successfully done here in
nebraska by protecting our hospital
capacity and not have the heavy gain of
government come in and tell people what
to do they just don't want to hear it
president biden was asked on friday
about
leaders governors like you who say
they're going to challenge him on the
vaccine mandates here's what his
response was
have at it
look
[Applause]
i am so um
disappointed
that
particularly some republican governors
have been so cavalier with the health of
these kids
so cavalier
for the health of their communities
governor are you being cavalier with the
health of your communities
what we're doing is focusing on
preserving our hospital capacity which
we've successfully done here in nebraska
we've got the third we're tied for the
third lowest mortality rate of any state
in the country for people who have
contracted covet 19 and so we protected
that hospital capacity to provide that
care and again we can look at the data
specifically around children and see the
risk last year in nebraska if you were
aged 10 to 19 you were 26 times more
likely to die in a car accident than you
were of covet 19. so the president
should look at the data and maybe the
president should attend one of the
weekly calls his administration has with
all the governors he's not been on one
yet since he's been president and maybe
talk to some of the governors and ask
them about what's going on in their
states because he appears to be pretty
ignorant of what's going on in places
like nebraska
let's talk about the covid situation in
your state and again it's not just about
kids it's about the entire population
let me put the
stats up on the screen back in june
nebraska was averaging 23 new cases a
day
now with a delta surge you're averaging
759 new cases a day
governor that's the highest since last
winter
yeah and again what we focus on is
preserving our hospital capacity and
that we have seen steady increase in
hospitalizations throughout the course
this summer here in the month of
september the number of hospitalizations
is bouncing around between 379 and then
on friday it dropped down to 350 so it's
been in that range through most of
september and that is in
contrast to the 987 we had at our peak
in november of 2020. so you can see
we're well below where we reached our
peak last year we did declare a staffing
emergency for hospitals to be able to
help them manage their
their
folks you know to make it easier to
bring in nurses and so forth but what we
focus on is providing that hospital
capacity we set up a transfer center to
be able to move people around between
hospitals statewide and all that to make
sure protecting the hospital capacity
that's our guiding star here in nebraska
and we've done it very successfully as i
indicated with our success in keeping
people uh you know from dying from this
disease i want to talk to you about that
because i i looked into the situation
the stress on hospital staffing and
hospital beds and the fact is on
september 1st you announced your state
was opening a hospital transfer center
that would allow patients to be moved
around in case there wasn't enough staff
or beds in one place you also have
directed health measures to limit
elective surgeries and one of your top
health officials says the fact is there
isn't enough room in your hospitals by
the end of each day
for high level care
actually what we've done is move the
people around if we needed to that's
what the transfer center is for to make
it easier for hospitals who want to move
a patient to get more acute care to be
able to officially move that person into
a hospital this primarily happens when
you've got say a more rural hospital
setting that may not have all the
facilities that maybe some of our urban
centers do and allow them to efficiently
get that to the right hospital and
certainly we are encouraging people to
continue to get vaccinated as part of
this but we're managing our hospital
capacity very successfully here in the
state with the tools that we've provided
with this staffing emergency so so i
asked you a question at the top you know
i asked you what why it was so
objectionable that you answered that you
didn't answer the other question let's
finish with that what are you going to
do about president biden's vaccine
mandates
yeah so i've been
talking to my attorney general he's
coordinating with the other attorneys
general across the country who share
similar views about the overreach this
is an egregious overreach of federal
authority and as we see what these rules
are we will be able to know exactly how
we will be able to challenge them in
court i'm also talking with
my colleagues around the country as well
the other governors who feel the way i
do and we'll be working on other
strategies but i got to tell you i've
heard from so many workers so many small
businesses who say this is just not
going to be something they can handle
so many people have told me they're just
going to be fired if they're forced to
take the vaccine this is really going to
create huge problems for our small
businesses and for our american workers
and again you shouldn't have to make the
choice of keeping your job or getting a
jab in the arm very briefly
you say you're going to court any idea
how soon
well when we get to an idea of what
these rules exactly will be we'll know
how to be able to attack it in court
governor ricketts thank you thanks for
your time today please come back sir
great thanks very much for having me on
chris